we've got good news for all you frozen
fans if you couldn't get enough frozen -
then you'll be happy to know that you'll
soon be able to own it that's right
Elsa and Anna and their newest adventure
are ready to come home
and that's not all the home release will
have a bunch of special features
including a sing-along behind the scenes
footage with the incredible cast and
lots of never-before-seen deleted scenes
keep watching to the end to see what we
can expect from these new scenes and how
they're gonna totally change the way we
see the movie
well that was unanimous and I'm still
gonna look it up when I get home
Disney just announced that frozen 2 will
be available digitally on February 11th
and on blu-ray and DVD on February 25th
2020 and both releases will feature tons
of behind-the-scenes looks at your
favorite characters cast members and
music there will be a total of 5 deleted
scenes and a closer look at - deleted
songs on the home release of frozen -
we'll also get to see the cast and
directors Jennifer Lee and Chris buck
talking about the creation of the film
where those deleted features fit into
the story and why they were cut in the
first place
turtles breathe through their butts and
I think that's something everyone should
know
to begin our journey down the lane of
deleted scenes there's an intro
featuring directors Jennifer Lee and
Chris buck that's going to offer us a
glimpse into their filmmaking process
this will include an explanation of the
five deleted scenes that didn't make the
final cut the first scene is a closer
look at the battle between arendelle and
the North aldrin in the scene a
mysterious figure challenges king eggnog
we don't know who this figure is but the
scene will offer us a closer look at
what started the battle and how it ended
up raging on for years has the Enchanted
Forest trapped it's angry resident
inside to fight amongst themselves
expect a fun deeper look at the history
behind the relationship between the
arendelle Ian's and the North aldrin in
the second deleted scene the sisters
find a secret room that reveals even
more of onon Elsa's past this includes a
shocking revelation about their mother
does this mean they'll find out that
their mother is North ultra a bit
earlier than they did in the final cut
looks like it or at least they'll be
given some more clues to help them on
their journey everything is a little bit
more grown-up
in this scene Anna gets a playful
glimpse into else's dream but it takes a
dark turn
we know that Elsa has a habit of letting
her powers come out when she's in
trouble
does she conjure playful snow visions in
her sleep only to have them morph into a
nightmare this seems likely and it'll be
a great chance for honor to see that her
sister has been plagued with anxiety and
doubts about her powers and place in the
world the next deleted scene stars
Kristoff who we really didn't get to see
much of in the final cut of the movie
ice cream castle oaken teapot Mouse in
the scene Kristoff reveals his true
feelings about life in arendelle when
the knock the horse shaped water spirit
won't take no for an answer does this
mean that the knock wants Kristoff to
join it in the enchanted forest
we know he has an affinity for animals
so this could be possible and he meets
the knock after it carries Elsa back to
the enchanted forest so the scene will
probably fit into this section of the
film but don't worry about Kristoff
leaving arendelle the end of the film
finds him back at home with Anna so it
doesn't seem like he agreed with the
knock when Elsa finds the cave it
reveals secrets about her parents in the
form of ice sculptures and visions in
the final deleted scene Elsa uses her
magic to soothe Anna's lingering doubts
about their parents faith in her after
all that Anna does to ensure the safety
of the North Ultra and the elemental
spirits we think that the scene is going
to be a well-deserved moment of praise
for the younger sister excuse me I
climbed the North Mountain survived a
frozen heart and saved you from my
ex-boyfriend and I did it all without
powers the deleted songs featured in the
film also reveal a few key differences
that would have totally changed the film
if they'd been kept while these songs
are available on the official frozen 2
soundtrack the blu-ray release will give
us a little more backstory
[Music]
like the deleted scenes the deleted
songs will be introduced by the
directors who give a little insight into
why they weren't included but why they
thought they were good enough to record
and release anyways we might also get a
little peek at other songs that were
written but didn't make it into the
recording studio the first song is
called home and features on us singing
about the home she loves as she walks
through arendelle the song would have
fit right in with the beginning of the
film honest things about a salty breeze
and creaky ships as she presumably walks
along the water overlooking her kingdom
it's a happy-go-lucky song that probably
didn't make sense in the film since
there was already the song some things
never change
in this song Olaf Anna Kristoff and Elsa
sing about how much they love their
family friends in arendelle
we support the decision to make sure the
opening number includes all the major
cast members but home is definitely
still worth a listen even if it's just
for Kristen Bell's phenomenal voice I
want to get this right is probably the
song that would have changed the movie
the most it's a fun duet that features
Kristoff and Hana getting engaged in an
entirely different way than what we
thought went down in the film with
lyrics about Kristoff forgetting the
ring and picking an awful time to
propose which is so typically Kristoff
this scene would have fit right in
during game night at the sisters home
when Kristoff was first planning to
propose the key to this and I say have
fun play with whatever you come up with
is Elsa is so bad
x-rated it's almost impossible to come
up with writing the song even ends with
Anna popping the question this would
have caused the couple to get engaged a
whole lot sooner than they did in the
film's final cut how different would the
movie have been if Kristoff and Anna
were already engaged the whole time they
were in the enchanted forest these
deleted songs aren't the only musical
bonus included on the home releases
there are also official music videos for
some of the movie's best songs Panic at
the Disco performs their version of
Elsa's ballad into the unknown in a
music video starring frontman Brendon
Urie which puts a totally different spin
on the tune and Weezer also has a music
video for their version of lost in the
woods an eighties glam rock jam that's
performed by Kristoff and his reindeer
in the film in addition there's a 29
language version of into the unknown in
the form of a music videos so that
everyone can sing along with Elsa
there's also a segment titled scoring a
sequel which will document composer
Kristoff back as you come
mine's a 91 piece Orchestra with 30
choral voices to create the movie's
magical score each song is crafted for a
specific moment in the in the story they
don't want to just write a great song
they want to write a great song that
services a bigger overarching story for
those of you are super excited to sing
along with all of your favorite songs in
the comfort of your own home the release
will of course come with a sing-along
version of the movie and if you only
want to sing certain songs then you can
use the Handy song selection feature to
jump to certain musical moments with
on-screen lyrics included while animated
deleted moments might be the most
exciting part of the release we'll also
get a chance to see the cast in action
and learn more about frozen than we ever
have before there will be a section of
cast outtakes included in the release
this behind the scenes footage will show
stars Kristen Bell Idina Menzel Jonathan
Groff and Josh GAD goofing around and
having fun as they record their lines
and sing their songs it'll also give us
an inside look at how the process for
recording frozen 2 works expect some
laugh-out-loud moments and some juicy
behind-the-scenes secrets I need to ask
you a question if the creation process
behind the movie is of particular
interest to you then you can also check
out the gale tests included on the
blu-ray which highlight how the
animators studied and created the
amazing wind effects in the film in an
effort to give personality to something
that's invisible and in-between here
she'll start swimming this includes an
animated short about two kids playing
tag and some hand drawings that helped
bring the wind spirit to life and if the
history behind the wind spirit and other
elemental sounds pretty cool to you then
check out the spirits of frozen to a
segment where both the cast and crew
explore the Scandinavian and Nordic
mythology that inspired the elemental
spirits and the enchanted forest
this will include secret knowledge about
the spirits that even the movie didn't
show us so be excited to find out more
about these magical mythical beings for
some of the most fun most surprising
frozen facts the bonus features turn to
Olaf in a segment called did you know as
we discover frozen to fun facts Easter
eggs and little tidbits about the making
of the film be prepared for our favorite
snowman to spill the dirt on the things
we might have missed in the movie and
behind-the-scenes gossip that we had no
idea about as well as callbacks to the
first frozen film that might have gone
right over our heads that's going to
make me question myself and things
around me and allow
use critical thinking leave it to Olaf
to fill us all in and finally if you're
not a big fan of blu-rays and DVDs then
the digital release also has a couple of
bonus features that you could check out
first how about the husband and wife
team behind the music from frozen 1 & 2
in meet the Lopezes we'll get an inside
look at the writing and recording of
some of our favorite frozen tunes and
what about the incredible lack of Olaf
related content included in the movies
deleted scenes well it seems like they
tried to use most of his scenes in the
final cut but the digital version will
have an unreleased Olaf song the deleted
song is called unmelted and it's Olaf
celebratory song about his newfound
freedom from well melting if all of this
isn't enough then we also have a
documentary about the creation of frozen
to look forward to it'll be in the multi
episode series titled into the unknown
making frozen too and we'll explore how
the voice cast directors and team of
artists came together to create the
Disney masterpiece we're not sure when
exactly to expect it but Disney
announced it'll be out within the first
year of the streaming platform so expect
it sometime in the near future
what bonus features are you most excited
for do you think the deleted scenes
would have totally changed the movie for
you let us know in the comments thanks
for watching don't forget to Like and
subscribe to the things for more content
you love wait as iconic as also Kristoff
Sven and all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]